tenemos aquí estas dos gráficas que se
ven muy parecidas y nos dicen que
escribamos una fórmula para la función g
en términos de la función f y bueno como
siempre vamos a resolver este ejercicio
si es que ponle pausa e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta
bueno ahora sí vamos a resolverlo a mí
lo que me gusta hacer es fijarme en este
punto mínimo de aquí porque lo tienen
estas dos funciones y lo que queremos
hacer es encontrar una forma de
trasladar a esta gráfica para que quede
exactamente encima de esta otra y para
que pase eso este punto mínimo tiene que
estar exactamente encima de este otro
punto mínimo así es que cómo le hacemos
para trasladar a esta función y a este
punto mínimo para que quede justo encima
de este otro y bueno tal vez lo primero
que se nos ocurre es que queremos
trasladar esta gráfica hacia la
izquierda no os gustaría trasladar
cuatro lugares hacia la izquierda o eso
también lo podemos decir como que nos
gustaría trasladarnos -4 y luego pues
también los queremos trasladar hacia
abajo nos queremos trasladar desde que
ya es igual a 2 hasta que ya es igual a
menos 5 así es que nos trasladamos hacia
abajo y podemos decir que nos
trasladamos hacia abajo 7 unidades o
podríamos decir que nos trasladamos
menos 7 y entonces ahora sí nos podemos
preguntar cómo escribimos ag en términos
de f sí que es la función f
pero cuando la trasladamos cuatro
unidades hacia la izquierda y siete
unidades hacia abajo o bueno si
trasladamos a efe - cuatro en el eje
horizontal y menos siete en el eje
vertical y una forma de pensar en todo
esto es decir que g
x es igual a efe pero evaluada en x
menos la traslación horizontal
traslación horizontal más la traslación
vertical gray más la traslación vertical
traslación vertical así es que nos
podemos preguntar oye por aquí cuál es
nuestra traslación horizontal bueno la
tenemos por aquí estamos trasladando a
efe cuatro lugares hacia la izquierda
así es que tenemos una traslación
negativa de menos cuatro y luego cuál es
la traslación vertical pues bueno
hicimos una traslación de siete lugares
hacia abajo
así es que también es una traslación
negativa por lo que la traslación
vertical es menos 7 y listo entonces lo
que nos queda es que g
es igual a efe de y aquí tenemos x menos
menos cuatro así es que es un x más 4 +
menos 7 pero eso es simplemente menos 7
ahora esta parte de menos 7 es la más
intuitiva de todas cierto porque aquí
estamos trasladando a la función hacia
abajo entonces es natural tener un -7
pero luego en esta parte esa no es tan
intuitiva porque aquí estamos
trasladando hacia la izquierda
entonces nos podemos preguntar que por
qué no aquí hay un signo negativo ahora
la forma en la que yo pienso en esto de
aquí es que si por ejemplo aquí
quisiéramos tomar la equis con la cual
aquí estuviéramos evaluando a efe pero
en cero pues esa equis tendría que ser
menos 4 que es justo esta traslación
entonces para que en esta función
estamos evaluando a efe en cero tenemos
que evaluar a la g en menos cuatro así
es que podemos pensar como que estamos
trasladando la
a cuatro lugares hacia la izquierda
ahora siempre es una muy buena idea
tomar algunos puntos evaluarlos en la
función y verificar que realmente se
están trasladando cómo se tienen que
trasladar ahora para que quede súper
claro esto de la traslación horizontal
te recomiendo que hagas ejercicios como
estos pero bueno de hecho ni siquiera
como estos ejercicios más simples donde
no hay traslación vertical porque hay
donde las funciones solo se trasladan en
el sentido horizontal y así lo vas a
entender súper rápido y se vuelve
también muy intuitivo pero bueno ya
tenemos otros vídeos que ven esa parte a
profundidad así es que vamos a ver otro
ejemplo bueno vamos con otro ejercicio
tenemos aquí la gráfica de g de x y la
gráfica de fx y nos dicen que dado que f
de x es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x
más 4 -2 tenemos que escribir una
expresión para g
en términos de x pero bueno lo primero
que vamos a hacer es escribir a la
función g x en términos de la función f
x que como podemos observar por aquí es
simplemente una traslación de la función
f así es que podemos recordar que y lo
voy a escribir aquí rápidamente
g de x es igual a efe de x menos la
traslación horizontal traslación
horizontal más la traslación vertical
entonces si queremos trasladarnos de f
cuál es la traslación horizontal bueno
pues podemos tomar este punto de aquí el
cual debería de ser trasladado a este
otro punto de acá y entonces podemos ver
que la traslación horizontal es de 2
unidades hacia la izquierda o también
podemos decir que es una traslación
horizontal de menos 2 si es que nuestra
traslación horizontal es de menos 2 y
cuál es la traslación vertical
bueno pues tenemos una traslación desde
menos 2 hasta 3 así es que nos estamos
trasladando 5 unidades hacia arriba
esta es una traslación vertical de más 5
sucre y la traslación vertical es de 5
así es que si queremos escribir hdx en
términos de fx como lo hicimos en el
ejercicio pasado lo que tenemos es que g
de x
de x es igual a efe de x menos menos 2 o
sea f x + 2 y luego tenemos más 5 + 5
pero eso no es precisamente lo que nos
están pidiendo aquí nos piden que
expresemos ag x pero en términos de x y
entonces vamos a tener que utilizar la
definición de fx que nos están dando
aquí aunque hoy aquí tenemos a gd x en
términos de fx pero sabemos que ese de x
es igual a la raíz cuadrada de x más 4 -
2 y ya que tenemos aquí escrita la
definición de fx la verdad es que nos
interesa saber cuánto vale efe
pero de x + 2 así es que vamos a
calcular
efe de x + 2 y lo único que tenemos que
hacer es aquí cada vez que veamos una x
cambiarla por una x + 2 porque así es
que tenemos la raíz cuadrada de x + 2
x 2 + 4 + 4 - 2 - 2 lo cual es igual a
la raíz cuadrada de x + 2 + 4 o sea x +
6 y finalmente menos 2 bueno entonces
esto de aquí es fx más 2 pero todavía
nos falta sumarle 5 para obtener gdx así
es que estamos buscando
efe de x + 2 + 5 y esto es igual a esto
que tenemos por aquí más 5 que es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de x +
- 2 y vamos a ponerlo de rosa + 5 gray
este 5 es este más 5 de aquí así es que
nos queda la raíz cuadrada de x + 6 - 2
+ 5 eso es más 3 y esto es la g de x
pero bueno veamos paso por paso qué es
lo que hicimos por aquí expresamos
primero a g de x en términos de fx lo
que vivimos que teníamos que trasladar a
efe de x 2 unidades hacia la izquierda y
por eso teníamos aquí un traslado de
menos 2 que por aquí aparece como un +2
así es que si en la fórmula aparece efe
de x + 2 estamos trasladando a la f dos
unidades hacia la izquierda como vimos
en el vídeo pasado y si aparece por aquí
un menos estaríamos trasladando a la f
dos unidades a la derecha y luego
también trasladamos a la función f 5
unidades
arriba pero bueno ya que tenemos aquí a
la función g en términos de f
recordamos que nos dieron la definición
de fx aunque hoy lo escribimos por aquí
porque queremos expresar a g en términos
de x pero bueno ya que tenemos aquí a la
función fx nos preguntamos cuánto vale
efe de x + 2 y bueno aquí lo único que
tuvimos que hacer para obtenerlo es
sustituir a la x por una x + 2 pero pues
después de eso todavía nos falta va a
sumar un +5 aunque porque la gtx es f de
x + 2 + 5 y todavía nos faltaba ese
pedazo así es que por aquí pusimos a efe
de x + 2 y luego le sumamos 5 y eso nos
da a g de x y entonces ahora si ya
terminamos